Alex Jones is now two kinds of bankrupt
morally and personally with hundreds of
millions of dollars of nutritional
supplement sales to his name as well as
1.5 billion dollars in legal judgments
the conspiracy theorist now says that
he's broke by which he means he's forced
to live on a paltry ten thousand dollars
a week that his company Free Speech
systems is paying him now that it too
has declared itself bankrupt must be
rough but is Jones really bankrupt or is
this all a massive Dodge or does he just
need to take an extra dose of super male
Vitality pills and show the haters
what's what now Alex Jones had a bad
year in 2022 it started off in January
when he was forced to testify before the
January 6th select committee and forgot
how to spell his own name in August a
jury in Texas found him liable for 42.5
million dollars in Damages to Neil
hesslin and Scarlett Lewis whose
six-year-old son Jesse Lewis was killed
in the 2012 Sandy Hook school massacre
and in November a group of Sandy Hook
parents were awarded more than 1.4
billion dollars in compensatory
impunitive damages by during kinetic
after Jones called them crisis actors
and accused them of faking their own
children's deaths to Gin up support for
gun control along the way Free Speech
systems the company Jones owns and runs
his infowar show through declared
bankruptcy then after the second jury
verdict Jones himself filed for personal
bankruptcy but on the plus side he's
probably the first guy to ever go on the
air and call the judge presiding over
his case a quote dwarf Goblin even in
third world dictatorships when they have
kangaroo courts they don't have the
judge tell the jury
this person is guilty
but she says up there it's a special
case
and they're all caricatures of what you
would imagine in some alternate universe
of
dwarf goblins
it's demonic they all act demonically
possessed the judge the lawyers plus
thanks to Jones and his lawyers attorney
Mark Bankston will probably never have
to buy himself a drink ever again after
his real-life Perry Mason moment so you
did get my text messages
and said you didn't nice trick
yes Mr Johnson indeed
you didn't give this text message to me
you don't you don't know where this came
from do you know where I got this no
Mr Jones
did you know that 12 days ago
12 days ago
your attorney's messed up they sent me
an entire digital copy of your entire
cell phone with every text message
you've sent for the past two years and
when informed did not take any steps to
identify it as privileged or protected
in any way and as of two days ago it
fell free and clear into my possession
and that is how I know you lied to me or
you said you didn't have to text message
about saying you know did you know that
I see I told you the truth this is your
Perry Mason moment so you know there
were some high points too but is Jones
really bankrupt well it's complicated
because there are several different
kinds of bankruptcy but for today we're
only concerned with chapter 11 AKA
reorganization this type of bankruptcy
is for businesses which could be
profitable if they could just get out
from under some of their debts and in
general the business owner known as the
debtor remains in possession of the
business meaning that they run the
day-to-day operations while negotiating
with creditors under the supervision of
the court in chapter 11 cases the
government is represented by the U.S
trustee and employ employee of the
justice department whose job is quote to
promote the integrity and efficiency of
the bankruptcy system for the benefit of
all stakeholders debtors creditors and
the public which means all the things
that you think it means and also that
the US trustee makes sure that the
debtor doesn't conspire with say one of
the other creditors to defraud either
the government or the other creditors
which may or may not become important to
our story in a moment oh thanks Freddie
foreshadowing now chapter 11 is a pretty
expensive process and if you're in
bankruptcy by definition you don't have
a lot of cash so in 2019 Congress passed
the small business reorganization act to
make it cheaper and faster for mom and
pop businesses without a lot of assets
to get into and out of bankruptcy call
it chapter 11 light or sub chapter 5 to
its friends now originally this
provision was intended for businesses
with debts under 2.7 million but during
covid Congress raised the threshold to
7.5 million in debts to unaffiliated
entities that is creditors unrelated to
the debtor can we get that Archer
animated gif again guys oh thanks
Freddie foreshadowing thanks now every
sub chapter 5 filing gets its own
special sub chapter 5 trustee whose job
it is to Corral the creditors and the
debtor to reach a speedy consensus to
divide up the corporate assets so that
everyone can be on their merry way even
better the court has the power to impose
a cram down essentially forcing the
creditors to accept a lower valuation of
their claims you can see why this would
be appealing to a company facing say 1.5
billion dollars in Damages after its
founder spent years calling the mass
shooting of children a hoax now in a
normal World a company with that kind of
debt would be ineligible for sub chapter
5 bankruptcy but free speech systems the
company which owns Infowars got it right
under the wire racing into bankruptcy
court at the end of the first Sandy Hook
tort case before the jury had a chance
to assess damages against it so why was
the company claiming to be broke and in
need of protection by the bankruptcy
court well it has to do with a Nevada
shell company known as pqpr Holdings
Limited LLC pqpr supplies the
nutritional supplements such as the 1776
testosterone boost and fizzy magnesium
drink powder that can bring in upwards
of half a million dollars a week in
sales for Infowars I mean what kind of
idiots are actually buying these
nonsense up oh
yeah the kind of people that watch
Infowars right now in late 2021 when it
became clear that Jones was going to
have to face the Sandy Hook plaintiffs
in court pqpr suddenly remembered that
it hadn't build Free Speech systems for
several years worth of beat tincture and
ultimate bone broth how do you forget to
invoice upwards of 50 million dollars in
Goods that's uh that's a mystery we're
gonna have to find out uh though I think
we all probably know what the answer is
there but we do know that FSS executed
two promissory notes in 2021
securitizing debts to pqpr totaling more
than 53 million dollars essentially that
put pqpr first in line for the creditors
to get paid but how can FSS be in sub
chapter 5 which is for companies with
debts under 7.5 million well there's an
exception in the law for debts to
affiliate entities I.E companies or
individuals who are related to the
debtor and surprise pqpr is wholly owned
by Alex Jones and his parents David and
Carol so it's excluded from that
calculation which is extremely
convenient here here since FSS which is
wholly owned by Alex Jones can take
advantage of the quick and dirty mom and
pop bankruptcy under sub chapter 5 while
claiming the pqpr is entitled to be paid
of all of fss's profits for the
foreseeable future basically Alex Jones
gets to claim that his right pocket FSS
owes his left pocket pqpr so much money
that there's none left for anybody else
unsurprisingly the Sandy Hook plaintiffs
are not happy about this in April of
2022 they filed a lawsuit in State Court
under the Texas uniform fraudulent
transfer act alleging that the
promissory notes are fraudulent and that
Jones personally siphoned 18 million
dollars out of FSS between 2018 and 2021
as part of an illegal scheme to make his
company litigation proof now the
plaintiffs also challenged the pqpr debt
in bankruptcy court urging the judge to
reject the promissory notes as
fraudulent pqpr objected in a response
which consistently referred to the
movements as the Shady Hook plaintiffs
just a glutton for punishment there they
later amended to use the proper name of
the school where the plaintiff family
members were slain U.S bankruptcy court
judge Christopher Lopez approved the
plaintiff's motion and the sub chapter 5
trustee is now investigating the pqpr
notes the drug supplier is an active
participant in the FSS bankruptcy
demanding an even greater share of the
company's profits threatening to cut off
the bone broth spigot if it isn't paid
and objecting to any and all oversight
which stands to reason since Alex Jones
and his parents control both pqpr and
FSS meanwhile back in Texas and
Connecticut state courts Alex Jones had
a problem because he and FSS were
co-defendants in the Sandy Hook suits
with FSS tied up in bankruptcy that left
him on the hook for the entire 1.5
billion dollars now the corporate
Shenanigans are interesting in their own
right but what about Jones's personal
bankruptcy well meanwhile back in Texas
and Connecticut state courts Alex Jones
had a problem because he and FSS were
co-defendants in the Sandy Hook suits
but with FSS tied up in bankruptcy that
left him on the hook for the entire 1.5
billion judgment so on December 2nd
Jones himself sought protection from the
bankruptcy court in one of his initial
filings he claimed assets less than 12
million dollars including administrative
costs due from fss2 Jones of
approximately 1 million dollars he also
made it clear that he doesn't intend to
give up his show and he intends to use
the bankruptcy to force the Sandy Hook
plaintiffs to accept a massive haircuts
on their legal settlements I'm going to
make him an offer again with you in the
status report Jones's lawyer said quote
while Jones comes to this court in good
faith and wants to reach an amicable
resolution between all the parties it is
imperative that all parties do the same
any argument that Jones must give up his
public life or discontinue public
discourse is contrary to supporting his
ability to fund a plan and pay creditors
leaving Jones with limited options
Jones's intention is to continue his
broadcast and the Alex Jones Show and
simultaneously proceed with this chapter
11 acting in the best interests of the
estate and the creditors participating
in good faith in the mediation process
and filling all obligations for
information transparency in pursuit of a
fair and reasonable compromise and
settlement he claims to be quote the
process of hiring and educating a
reputable financial advisor to clean up
the mess in his personal and business
bookkeeping which definitely 100 is not
his fault his lawyers also argue quote
Jones's attention over the last few
years has been focused on his talk show
and his family and thus his personal
finances somewhat disorganized are being
reviewed and analyzed to ensure Clarity
and integrity of information going
forward Jones and FSS lost a great deal
of money trusting people who did not
have the ability or the character to
handle the finances they also claimed
that he fronted 10.3 million dollars to
keep FSS afloat in the past year
although according to the Sandy Hook
plaintiffs FSS was at the same time
shoveling a mountain of cash out the
door to pqpr it amounts as high as
eleven thousand dollars per day there's
also reporting that Anonymous donors
sent Jones eight million dollars with
Bitcoin in 2022 cash which he pocketed
according to the testimony by his
corporate representative in the
Connecticut trial but it's clear that
there's money floating around somewhere
and we know that because lawyers and
bankruptcy have to disclose their
compensation and Jones has two law firms
representing him in this case attorney
Shelby Jones says that he receives 688
thousand dollars to represent Jones in
the proceeding prior to filing the
bankruptcy petition while attorney Vicki
driver says that she's agreed to accept
half a million dollars for her Services
of which she's already been paid forty
eight thousand dollars but none of the
money already paid came from Jones
himself instead The Source was a
mysterious entity known as the Missouri
779-384 trust now at this point you're
probably asking yourself what is the
Missouri
779384 trust and where did it get seven
hundred thousand dollars to spend on
Alex Jones's legal bills that is a very
very good question and the answer is
Alex Jones knows but he's not saying so
what is Alex Jones saying well he's
saying
on December 16th Jones filed a motion
demanding to be paid his entire 1.3
million dollar annual salary from FSS
rather than the measly ten thousand
dollars per week authorized by the court
in bankruptcy Jones's lawyers wrote
quote the amount authorized for fss's
payments of Jones salary in the interim
orders to date is a severe reduction
from the salary Jones is due under the
agreement before adding that their
client quote wholly fulfilled his
employment obligations to render the
content creation advertisement and
promotional Services Under the
employment contract from April 14 2022
and quote continues to expend personal
funds for fss's expenses yes that's
right Jones wants to be reimbursed for
any money that he Advanced toward the
company of which he is the sole owner in
which he claims is bankrupt thanks to a
50 million dollar debt to himself now
the court has shown limited patience for
Jones's monetary demands back when Free
Speech systems first filed for
bankruptcy he requested reimbursement
for 172 thousand dollars some un
itemized expenses accrued on a company
credit card which he used to pay for
things like housekeeping and his
personal residence uh Judge Lopez denied
the expense refusing to let FSS pick up
the bill but at a December 19th hearing
the court was more receptive to Jones's
argument that there is no FSS without
him as the pitch man and the Court's job
here is to maximize the estate I.E the
pot of money that can be used to pay off
creditors so while the Sandy Hook
plaintiffs as well as the U.S trustee
and the sub chapter 5 trustee
unanimously objected to raising Jones's
compensation the court pointed out that
if Jones stops showing up for work
Infowars won't be able to sell any more
brain Force plus pills and the whole
operation would grind to a halt which
would affect the ability to pay off all
the creditors quoting Judge Lopez quote
revenue is generated through the sale of
product and he's the guy who can sell it
but Jones lawyer Vicki driver made a
fairly unsubtle threat that Jones might
just take his krill oil Hawking skills
elsewhere if the court won't pay the
bill saying quote right now Mr Jones can
and may be forced to take third party
employment if he cannot make what he
needs to survive at the hearing Judge
Lopez postponed the decision on Jones's
salary for another month and in an
emergency motion filed two days later
Jones again demanded that the court
restore his full salary under the terms
of the employment agreement as he signed
with himself as 100 owner of FSS
basically he demands no reduction in
money due to him unlike the Sandy Hook
plaintiffs whom he insists will have to
take a big haircut and in another
emergency motion filed the same day in
his personal bankruptcy case Jones
demanded that the court authorized
Utility payments to keep the lights and
internet on at his properties these
include three condominiums in Austin and
a lake house in Travis County as well as
his personal residence in Austin which
he transferred to his wife's name in
February of 2022. Jones's lawyers argue
that protecting his quote individual
well-being as well as his children and
the continued operations of his
businesses require maintaining
subscriptions to Netflix Hulu HBO Max
and fire stick and we'll run to almost
five thousand dollars monthly which is a
lot of TV for a guy who regularly rails
against the Deep State Hollywood now he
also had quite a bit to say on his own
show about his pending legal troubles
Jones watched the verdict being read out
live laughing as he assured his audience
that it could safely stock up on Ultra
Blue aromatherapy oil without worrying
that the proceeds would go to grieving
parents of slain children and in a
pre-Christmas message Jones explicitly
characterized the sub chapter 5 filing
as a means of waiting out the Sandy Hook
plaintiffs and denying them any recovery
now remember I'm in bankruptcy we got
two years of appeals the money you
donate does not go to these people it
goes to fight this fraud and it goes to
stabilize the company he did not state
that it goes to pay off a 50 million
debt or possibly debt to pqpr a company
owned by Jones and his parents Jones
went on to warn his followers not to
believe the story his own lawyers are
painting in court of an operation
running deep in the red and facing
Financial ruin or at least not to the
extent that they give up hope and quit
sending him cash for super blue fluoride
free toothpaste on the show Jones
shouted we are in bankruptcy to try to
get through this and to try to minimize
the bills and then a bunch of the
audience thinks well he's going off air
I'm not going to support no it's chapter
11 sub chapter 5. all we got to do is
have a plan make it through the plan and
we stay on air indefinitely and they
can't shut us down and we get our
appeals implying that selling just a few
more vials of lung Cleanse Plus would
mean the difference between life and
death for the site now this is a risky
Gambit for someone who already got
chased out of Bankruptcy Court after
placing three worthless shell companies
in chapter 11 last April and what the
U.S trustee described as quote classic
bad faith filings which quote were filed
to gain a tactical advantage in the
Sandy Hook lawsuits using quote a novel
and dangerous tactic that is abusive and
undermines the Integrity of the
bankruptcy system and you might recall
that Jones's obnoxious behavior and
Defiance of court orders already got him
sanctioned by both Sandy Hook state
judges and his comments on air about
pending litigation have come back to
bite him in the past that first
bankruptcy case was derailed in part
because his attorney Norm patus accused
the Sandy Hook families of staging a
quote Macabre morality play admitting to
the Wall Street Journal that Jones was
quote turning to the bankruptcy courts
to compel the plaintiffs to estimate the
value of their claims in open court by
discernible evidentiary standards and
when Jones and Infowars host Owen
Shroyer discussed the Texas case on air
during the trial with Jones deriding the
jury as quote extremely blue-collar
folks who do not know what planet
they're on and describing the father of
the same child is slow and on the
Spectrum the plaintiffs immediately Play
that video in open court and kidding
let's just say this extremely
blue-collar folks
where people do not know what planet
they are on so it's a pretty safe bet
that the San Diego plaintiffs are going
to tell Judge Lopez about the latest
video of Jones suggesting that Infowars
is financially stable and the bankruptcy
is simply a means to stiff his creditors
and on December 22nd Connecticut
Superior Court Judge Barbara Bellis
refused to overturn the massive jury
award ruling that the jury quote
discharges obligations conscientiously
dutifully and according to the state's
instructions on the law to be applied
now Jones has already filed appeals of
both cases seeking to overturn the
verdicts or at least get the awards
reduced but with this much money on the
line the plaintiffs have every incentive
to ignore Jones's threats to get them to
negotiate and they're also trying to
convince Judge Lopez to rule of the pqpr
notes where fraudulent transfers made
with the intent of looting the company
in preparation for litigation and
bankruptcy and meanwhile Jones will show
up every day to flog HGH Max boost and
super male Vitality nonsense promising
that none of the money will ever go to
the plaintiffs and whining about
scraping by on a mirror five hundred and
twenty thousand dollars per year plus
five thousand dollars a month for
utilities uh yes uh naturally I can't
pay you much of a reward because I'm
strapped for cash
now they're gonna be a lot of
interesting twists and turns in the Alex
Jones bankruptcy in the coming months
but one thing is for sure it's going to
be a lot of fun to watch and you'll be
able to keep tabs on it with today's
sponsor morningbrew because that's my
favorite way to catch up with pop
culture and the news in fact you could
have already learned about Alex Jones
because morning Brew already covered him
when I wake up it is the first thing
that I read I've actually been
subscribed to morning Brew for forever
it's one of my absolute favorite
newsletters and I'm thrilled to tell you
why because morning Brew if you didn't
already know is a free daily newsletter
delivered Monday through Sunday it gets
you up to speed on business finance Tech
Law pop culture all in just five minutes
and it provides a fantastic quick
summary of the most important issues
while being witty irreverent and
informative and did I mention it's
completely free this week I learned all
about Tick Tock getting banned on
college campuses artists suing AI art
generators and the extremely polarizing
statute of Martin Luther King in Boston
it's basically exactly the mix of news
that I'm actually interested in and
stuff that I didn't even know that I
wanted to know about and it's all
written in a hilarious style morning
Brew is one of the few emails that I
actually open every single day so Legal
Eagles this one is a complete no-brainer
morning Brew is completely free and it
takes just 15 seconds to subscribe just
click on the link that's on screen right
now or in the description to get morning
Brew for free and not only we get a
newsletter that you'll actually read
you'll actually help out this channel
too so click on the link below to get
morning Brew right away and after that
click on this link over here for more
legal eagle or I'll see you in court